انتظر انتظر انتظر انتظر بدوره
ابتعدوا لقد ذهبنا بعيدا
[موسيقى]
السويدية في أوروبا
تم التوقيع عليها بالحرية والديمقراطية
كتابنا الأسمى القرآن
السماح بالحرق من قبل الشرطة
من العار أن تفعل ذلك
[موسيقى]
من ولايتنا
طلبنا من رئيسنا السويد
قطع كافة العلاقات مع الحكومة
انظروا، إنهم يريدون الانضمام إلى حلف شمال الأطلسي، الأوغاد و
مهد التنظيمات الإرهابية
الدولة لحلف شمال الأطلسي، حيث نحن أيضا
تركيا تريد الدخول كثيرا
هناك فرصة عظيمة
لا ينبغي
[تصفيق]
حسب تصريح السلطات السويدية
هذا الاستفزاز أمام السفارة
تحقيق العمل في جميع أنحاء العالم
المسلمين في جميع أنحاء العالم
الشباب
في جميع أنحاء العالم لتغضب
وهذا سوف يزعج المسلمين.
توافق على السماح
ليس من الممكن لهذا
تركيا لتحقيق هذا العمل.
ومن قبيل الصدفة أن يتم اختيار السفير.
لا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]